hey this interview is brought to you by
our good Folks at Imperial extractions
ladies and gentlemen now check this out
if you want a
free 2 G pre-roll delivered right to
your door they got you go get a free 2 G
thca Diamond infused pre-roll with any
order right now we're talking about 1
and half grams of top shell flour and a
half a gram of pure thca diamonds
Imperial extraction. comom promo code
bootleg and you're going to get this for
free delivered right to your door let's
get to the
interview all right man bootle C podcast
special guest here returning guest it is
designer con season it is we got the
homie Kevin from 3D retro and designer
Con in the building welcome man thank
you for having me again it's the time
yeah this year uh Big Year how many
years in a row is this now this is our
18th Year we're finally now you can buy
cigarettes yes yes yes designer and
drinking somewhere in the world some
places in the world designer can drink
alcohol and do other things yes for sure
um yo so this year too man like for
people who don't know if you guys didn't
see we had Kevin on the show last year
uh designer con is a really dope
convention that is in Orange County
every year uh well not every year right
it's been in different places uh it's
been different places for the first 13
years was in Pasadena but o OC is kind
of the home now the home now yeah so
it's uh how would you describe what
designer con is you kind of got walk
through it to really get a feel for it
but if you had to describe it well if I
had to describe it it's like a it's like
a toy convention but with emphasis on
the art and artists so it's a lot of
individual artists having independent
toys but then you get the bigger
companies that's uh has more of a
limited edition feel to it but it's not
like mass produced not like Mattel or
Hasbro they're not there it's guys like
overseas like metacom toy popmart that
makes we call it mass produced but the
tech technically not compar to us
standards uh they're more limited
edition runs what they do is once they
make something once it's sold out going
to it's gone forever yeah it's gone
forever they don't look back yeah so
like you could walk around there's
different toys there's different artists
selling like prints and like uh there's
collaborations between artists and toys
and it's it's just it's like dope
especially I feel like if you got kids
uh you you also could be a grownup cuz I
enjoyed myself but I took my son who was
eight 8 years old and he just loved it I
mean spent a bunch of money on [__] that
he didn't understand what he was buying
right he we were on the look for uh
squish mows everywhere squish see you
you might not you probably didn't find
that no we didn't but no actually there
was some one one random Booth had squish
Mellows right so it's not a lot of that
right but it's like I feel like you can
take your kids there and inspires them
there's a lot of things that they will
open their eyes cool and just cool sets
like there was like some guy in jail I
think there was like a jail set yeah it
was it was super cool cool man people
are creative like they're artists they
you they they they they think outside
the box for the booth you know 100% um
you every year you guys do limited
edition bear bricks for designer con
only yes is correct right um we partner
with different artists every year yeah
like last year I think I got like the
limited edition box that was the
designer com branding um I still have
that this year talk about some of
because I last year the guy I always
forget his name the obey guy I have the
bearry Shephard fery this year we got
Bobby hundred hundreds we got Bobby
hundred hundreds uh who all is a who all
is a part of like the bear brick
exclusives this year so we have shipper
coming back uh he's doing 1,000% of the
ones that we released last year so it's
a th% which is a bigger version and then
he's we're also doing one that is called
the make art not war design which he
posted earlier this year I think without
getting political I feel like this is
the right time for sure for that message
I agree uh so I think we we we we feel
like we should release this this year so
we're doing that um and then the artists
we have Bobby H hundreds the hundreds
Ben Hundreds they are celebrating their
20th anniversary this year yeah so we
came together a few years ago knowing
the fact that it's 20 years this year
right uh they have never done a bear
brick uh we kind of help collaborate you
know facilitate that and to celebrate
the 20th anniversary so we'll have a
special signing with them at the show
and the release will be at designer con
another one will be dabs Mila they're
artist duel they're located in La okay
uh they do a lot of um super bright
flower uh paintings uh graffiti like
murals uh they're part of the uh beyond
the street crew uh that world so they
have never done a beay brick and we have
one with them as well uh and then we
have this purple one right here
this one is so fly so this is a musician
he's a singer songwriter from Singapore
his name is JJ Lyn uh he's one of my
personal favorite artists you said he's
like the Michael Jackson of I call him
Michael Jackson of Asia his voice is
incredible as a singer uh you know a lot
of people use this what do you call Auto
Tune and all that stuff not you you go
to one of his concerts like in the early
especially early days when he was
younger you can hear the the voice with
without the auto tune it was beautiful
uh he did suffer a little bit of a vocal
thing string maybe s years ago B
recovered uh so it is his 20th
anniversary as a singer songwriter
coming out uh this year as well so he
has a world tour uh because we knew that
we kind of want to celebrate with a
special collab uh we went to metacom
saying cuz they had a US stop uh in the
US earlier this year we wanted to come
out at that time with the the smaller
one and then do the bigger one at
designer con unfortunately with
manufacturing [__] happen [__] happen so
we decided to move it all to designer
con he just wrapped up his tour in China
his 20 20th anniversary tour yeah he
just wrapped up the tour in China so
he'll be there he'll be here he'll be at
designer con Friday wow yeah yeah so so
you know for people who um if they let's
say they're like I want to go and I want
to get some of these limited edition
things now I went last year and I I
messed up I went on Sunday so a lot of
the stuff I wanted to buy was just gone
Friday Friday Friday is the play so
Friday is and how limited like for
example let's say these two how limited
are these uh I'm not supposed to say a
number but they're very Li under a th
okay so you got to get there for that
size under a thand sometimes on the
bigger versions under uh the th% is
under 500 pieces have you cuz I feel
like bear bricks have kind of like
became like this iconic I feel like it's
an entry point for a lot of people into
art and toys like a lot of people who
are kind of like generic Street Wear
guys who wear Supreme and whatever
whatever you you might go to their house
and they got bear bricks on the side of
their TVs it's synonymous it feels very
like much like an entry point for a lot
of people to get into art to get into
the toy game um for you like uh you
you've obviously you guys at uh 3D retro
carry a bunch of dope bear bricks you
guys just move
uh to Vegas from La yes um is is there
like there's bootleg bear bricks right
yes so how do you tell like if can you
tell if it's a fake bear brick or not I
can tell if I have it in my hand in
terms of the Finish you know uh how the
figure is made cuz that's a thing now
yeah yeah like there's bootleg toys I
didn't know this until like recently I
was on Amazon and uh my son no this what
happened my son sent me his Christmas
list like maybe three 3 weeks ago and he
sent me everything on Amazon and he sent
me a fake CA toy on Amazon and I was
like they're selling a $20 CA toy on
Amazon like what the [__] is going on
yeah unfortunately cause there's a lot
of bleake on that especially once you
get it you'll see it's completely
different the the original stuff or the
real stuff that he sells now with
metacom so on the bottom of these guys
there's a sticker oh I see the sticker
so that is the n FC authentication so if
you have your phone or anything like
that you scan it it'll tell you it's a
authentic product from metacom so they
started doing that what to come back so
you got to look out for the sticker you
got to look out for stickers but then
the other thing is it's just a finish
overall a lot of these are super smooth
like I couldn't imagine somebody pulling
off like a legit like this is a very
high Lev tool here it's not hard it's
not easy to this is crazy to duplicate
right so they don't do everything they
do super super popular or simple designs
or just a blank one what is your in your
opinion out of all the bear bricks
what's like the one everyone has what's
the most popular what's the one
everybody has what's the most what's no
like what's the most like generic bear
brick like you like ah yeah like that's
like easy to get that most people have I
would say a licensed character like a
like a Mickey or or those type Snoopy
you know um those type of character ones
or superheroes like Batman Superman
those the Batman one those those
are on the basic like somebody that just
got into this what have right like I
think most of us love playing action
figures Growing Up So for us those IPS
are be the first one you gravitate
towards right so when you look at a bear
brick and if you see an American IP most
Americans will go towards that like
Batman Superman yeah all that what about
what's the Holy Grail what's the two or
three Holy Grail ones I'm sure you
probably have one I think the the holy I
don't have the Holy Grill considered by
a lot of people there's a Gucci piece
right you have to be a VIP Ben Baller
has one but you have to be a VIP on the
list they make like a super limited
amount it was only for Gucci Gucci store
and all what is that if on the on the on
the aftermarket six
digits Jesus what's the most expens cuz
we talked about your toy collection last
time uh yeah it's pretty expensive what
is your like holy grail bear brick at
your crib I have a couple causes that's
worth about 20 25,000 each damn you know
so depends on Market when the market was
great it was here so right now it's
probably around that price it's crazy
too because like uh I see you know I'm
like an I have an addicted personality
which is why I haven't diving in too
much into the toy game because I am I
like I'm into comics and I'm into sports
and I'm I'm like the perfect Mark to
just eventually turn into DJ amen oh am
man is he's a [__] psychopath a
little bit he's
uh everything he collects everything at
this point and um I wonder for you
though like uh you know if
anybody if I mean you you've kind of
seen it like what where do most people
kind of start their toy collection like
that like based on like cuz you're on
the retail side too so you sell a lot of
toys I'm sure you'll see somebody come
in for the first time and then two years
later you're like man we're seeing you
every week here's for us to the the the
entry level will be the blind box the
little mystery boxes like when you're
kid the booster pack trading cards so a
lot of the brands do that like B Brick's
the smaller version they come in blind
boxes you can buy for $7 you never know
what you're going to get never what you
get there's like plenty of design choose
from so that's like the entry level drug
I call it right you get addicted to
opening that it's almost like the cards
right the basketball cards cuz you crack
a pack and you're like [__] I got to and
then if you get the the super rare one
it's worth a lot of money super rare oh
you going keep going right so that's
that's the for me that's what I see a
lot of inry level people the blind boxes
and then once they get into it they're
like they find artists that they like
they gravitates to whatever artist that
from cause to Steven Harington to you
know all these Ron English Gary basem
all these guys part of our world like
they start finding what they like for
their house for their hobby so they go
to the different artist is like we can
take CS everybody wants to collect CS
right so a lot of people go from find
blind boxes and go like I want my first
C piece you know a couple hundred bucks
and we we sell them at the store too cuz
we have some of our Personal Collection
nothing for wholesale they he doesn't do
wholesale know we get a couple extra
pieces and we we sell it to our store of
VIPs but they get addicted to that once
they have their first piece oh I want a
second piece I want a third one you know
so that's how you grow right and then
once you get there you're like once you
get past cause then you're going to go
like what else is there you want to kind
of mix different things then that's when
you get too far you're like I have a lot
of [__] at that point I was going to say
there's like another subculture of toys
that is I feel like it's kind of
somewhat very separate and different
from this and that's collecting
wrestling figurines uh yeah wrestling
figurines and bootleg wrestling figuring
there's like bootleg yeah cuz like my
son we have probably no [__] like 500
wrestling toys from the last like I
don't know 12 years or so I don't know
what kind of condition they're and
they're in his drawers but I always told
him don't ever get rid of your toys give
them to me like my kids no my kid's 18
now for the record so he's got all these
[__] I'm like never get rid of them
don't ever give them away I just you
know it's maybe it's like a connection
between him and me and his childhood
right but the wrestling game is so crazy
has Barrick ever done anything with the
WWE hey we got to stop the interview
real quick man shout out to our family
at my bookie NFL season is winding down
you still got some regular season uh
games you can get in on of course the
college bowl games are coming up so much
money to get plus the cash prizes going
down in their weekly Blackjack
tournaments at
mybookie.ag and uh this is what's going
on right uh my bookie is crazy because
they're doing this if you sign up right
now at mybookie use the promo code
bootleg all right claim your deposit
match redeemable up to $1,000 that's
right they're going to match your first
deposit up to
$11,000 using the promo code bootleg
claim your bonus NFL college bowl game
so much going on in terms of what you're
trying to get down with if you want to
gamble if you want to bet all right they
got Blackjack they got roulette they got
it all uh and of course the best odds
anywhere online when it comes to your
sports betting needs so one more time
sign up right now with that promo code
bootleg um and I'm going to tell
everybody this uh you're going to get
your first deposit match up to
$1,000 I'mma put my money I'm feeling
good about the 49ers future BET right
now slam the ners to win the Super Bowl
I think they're taking that whole oh
[__] bet anytime anywhere with my bookie
also shout out to our good folks over at
blueo make sure you go over to blue.com
right now a lot of people asking me yo
man blue Chu does that [__] work yeah it
works man find out for yourself though
blue Chu is legit same active ingredient
as viagr seis but if you want to know if
it works they're going to take care of
you with your first month for free by
using the promo code bootleg at blu.com
that's right blu.com use that promo code
bootleg and get your first month for
free this is how it goes down no awkward
doctor's visits none of that if you're
dealing with a rectile dysfunction
you're dealing with too much stress
maybe you're drinking a little too much
you get the whiskey dick I don't know
huh blueo got you all right blu.com
promo code bootleg sign up right now get
your first month supply for free
delivered right to your doorstep for
only $5 in shipping no uh doctor's
appoint it's all online discret
packaging in a blue chewable form come
on fellas it's getting cold outside
let's make sure those [__] stay hard
right all right let's get back to the
interview yeah we have two that just
came in recently to the store uh I
forgot I'm not a wrestling oh you're not
aest but people want it people want it
yeah it was there's a red he's wearing
red pants and a blue pants red plants uh
Cody Cody rhods might American Nightmare
there was two wrestlers that they've
done WWE so they they have done 400
presents not necessarily thousand
presents the the so tell me about this
Jordan one that's going to be at uh cuz
this just dropped the the video today we
just dropped the video so there's a
Jordan bear brick that's fire yes it's
the last shot 1998 NBA Finals um metacom
is releasing that overseas only so this
technically not for US
market but for designer con they're
bringing a super limited amount uh they
got permission from upper deck MBA to
release them only at designer con so we
have less than
100 big ones less than 50 100 that point
a very small amount a very small amount
um less than 200 of the smaller version
the
400% yeah but like right now the buzz so
the thing with that one is it's going to
be at designer conom before it releases
overseas yes so how how much more like
what's the like when is the the general
release overseas going to be there's the
it says December on their website but I
think they mean us I from what I was
told it was supposed to go released from
here and then Japan stores Singapore and
maau and that's it
so that's dope yeah overall how many
pieces it is a limited uh Edition I
remember the first one that came out was
the rookie year was gold that one uh
sold out instantly L and now it's worth
like 3 4,000 Jesus so for the bigger
size wow yeah so for us you know it's a
big deal to get this yeah I was
surprised I this one's like it's like
Chrome right it's silver Chrome silver
yeah yeah silver Chrome with the red
Chicago Bull jersey it's has a
14 on the feet the Jordan has a Jordan
logo too if it was the last shot it was
probably the Ferrari the 14 yeah the 14
yeah yeah so I I Wonder because during
the pandemic uh hard assets like toys
like Rolexes like basketball cards they
shot through the roof yeah they shot now
a lot of that stuff I'm not sure about
the toy Market but I know a lot of like
the sports cards market and the watch
Market has cooled off a little bit um
has the resale Market on the toy game
chilled out a bit in terms of where it
was yeah definitely uh in terms of let's
say taking the the collectible business
bear bricks they were at one one point
super hard to get everybody wanted price
G shot up through the roof in the
pandemic now that's kind of just like
everything else has kind of gone down
that's the reason why you know you
notice I haven't mentioned our five pack
M because well you guys do it every year
right we're not doing it this year due
to the market conditions that's what
metacon call it market conditions cuz
usually you guys have the designer con
five small you can get in the Box yes so
due to the market conditions they
decided not to do the five pack this
year okay they want to focus on these
collaborations uh anniversaries just so
that we can get these out um because
they don't want to make too many first
of all a lot of these exclusives uh 20th
anniversary ones were making super
limited amount and then they're going to
the artist and the brand right the
hundreds will have some for sale uh JJ
will have some for his fans so
everything's very contained and limited
so the only way to get it is to come to
the show so I was going to say for you
uh how much of your toy collecting is
investing for later and how much is it
DJ amen or I like to call DJ amen
because he's our friend if y'all don't
know go follow him DJ amen 3000 he's a
psychopath all his money goes to
Toys but I for you are you are you the
kind of guy who's like I'm gonna buy
this toy because in 20 years from now I
might be able to cash out and retire I'm
I'm a 50/50 Okay so for me like let's
let's for example let's say that Jordan
peace in my head and heart I already
want five cuz I know that's going to be
worth a lot right so do I want do I want
to give F of course cuz I want to have
one on display and have four sealed
right that's what I want to do so in my
head a lot of my stuff are if it's cool
and it's worth something that I can see
in the future I want to get two of three
of that's where my collection times
that's when you'll buy you'll be like
you know what almost like one to rock
one to stock with with the sneakers
which which I do with the sneakers too
yeah like I get minimum two pairs of
each if I can minimum you know like the
Kobe grinches the reverse that just came
r grinches i just forg got to pay for my
son I didn't even get one cuz I missed
out on that so I'm hoping I get one
there's a restock coming this weekend
well the actual release is this week oh
is it this weekend okay so I'm going to
hope I get at least two pairs you know
uh but a lot of the stuff like the 11s
even though nobody wanted them this year
the ones that just dropped just dropped
DMT guess what in 5 years 3 years
they're going to go up of course I got
two pairs you know I don't want I like
them too well they were hard to get when
they first dropped are you talking about
the great fools that just dropped with
the gold jordan the theing moments pack
oh yeah yeah they're part of that pack
yeah so I don't know why people are like
sleeping on it you know what's funny is
like um I just threw a few pairs up on
stockx just cuz like my my man cave is a
mess where I'm just like [__] dude I I
haven't worn these shoes I for 4 years
like right but there was a few shoes
that I bought that were sitting that
like like I got those all red threes mhm
that came out four years ago and I got
them for like 80 bucks on clearance and
now they're going for like 350 400 and
I'm like these like I I I I think I
don't know if I posted those or not but
it's funny I was just I was just going
through all my my dead stock shoes all
right just see what's and I was like a
lot of these shoes that nobody wanted
when they dropped but I'm a three guy
so I'll buy any threes as long as
they're not hideous I'm like damn these
threes these threes these threes some of
the fours that I have like I have these
pony hair all black premium fours that
like nobody wanted when they dropped and
I'm like damn like that's probably the
same thing with toys
too well a little bit yeah a little bit
I think a lot of times is artists too
for what we're are yeah so at a certain
point if an artist right now is not well
known but his stuff is relatively cheap
and limited you buy that he might
because cuz you're kind of investing in
the artist yeah just like it's like
cause right 30 years ago he's not what
he is now so if you had older pieces
it's worth a lot more so it is kind of
like that but like like like you said
about
Jordan's uh you know the certain models
are always good doesn't matter what kind
of color they put eventually when people
don't want them couple years later
they're they want them cuz they're done
right it's a limited edition it's a
limited edition yeah it's a limited
edition part of our nature this nature
same thing you don't get this bear brick
now you say oh I can get them next week
or next year but once they're sold out
then you got to pay secondary you
remember those animal print threes that
came out that had like all the animal
hair on two or three years ago yeah I
have those those are [__] fire when
they dropped they were so easy to get
right now they're going for bread yeah
and those were fire I'm like how' nobody
[__] with these when they Dro they were
so good I love I love those yeah those
were great hey what up y'all I'm excited
cuz I'm going to be flying to Tampa to
DJ the odd Sox holiday party next next
week and of course as y'all know odd
Soxs are OG sponsors our family the most
comfortable socks in the world want to
give much love to odd Soxs for always
holding us down at the boot Lake C
podcast now it is the holiday season
there ain't nothing like getting you a
pair of Odd Socks for your loved one
getting some underwear getting a hat
whatever you're into they got it
oddsocks official.com promo code boot
Lake save 20% off 20% off at checkout
right now all the licenses WWE uh I mean
Hooters
oh some hooters underwear let's take a
peek at these huh bunch of [__] owls
all over here there we go M I like it
what about Chucky ain't nothing like
some Chucky socks during the Christmas
you know hey whatever you're into they
got it oddsocks official.com use the
promo code bootleg right now save 20%
off uh and enjoy the most comfortable
socks in the world also want to give a
shout out to our family over there King
pom now that's the think about King pom
what I love about King pom no tobacco no
nicotine we're talking about
straight natural Leaf organic Leaf all
right and and and the cool thing is they
got these turpine infused tips when I
tell you they're turpine infused I mean
it like I love these ones shout out to
uh Sugar Shane sugar Shan [__] I almost
[__] his name up uh sugar Shan Ali
from Phoenix uh he's got his honey
orange here how it works you load that
thing up with your cannabis flow you got
that flavorful tip
inside bam that's what it looks like
when it's all done it's like a work of
art ladies and gent a work of art all
right go to your local smoke shop
wherever you're at they got King pom go
ask for King palom thank me later okay
King pom local smoke shop 7-Eleven they
got them or you can just go to the
website check this out go to the website
king pom.com take care of somebody in
your life that you love and get 50% off
everything you order at King pom.com
using the promo code bootleg
50% off that's half off half off King
pom.com that's what we're doing right
now all right let's get back to the
interview all right so so for people who
don't know designer cons this weekend
we're going to drop the episode tomorrow
so tomorrow will be Wednesday so if
you're watching this if you're in the LA
area you got to pull up man it's
definitely worth even if you're in like
Phoenix San Diego Vegas make the drive
look I made the drive I moved to
Vegas I was going to say you guys for
people who don't know guys are also
behind the store 3D retro right which
was based in kind of Burbank Glendo area
bbang Glendo I've been there for 10
years just moved to Vegas just moov to
Vegas this summer is it better yes I
feel like cuz you guys were in a
location where I don't feel like a lot
of people knew you were there in terms
of like generic generic traffic wise
right I feel like cuz I know where you
guys are in Vegas so you guys must get
just a lot more a lot more foot traffic
a lot more exposure now where we were
because cuz we owned the land in the
building uh so we put murals and all
that stuff oh yeah yeah it was sick it
it was beautiful but the thing is la is
so big like it's travel from one point
to another point to go to glendell on a
traffic yeah if someone lives in Gardina
or something they don't want to go right
at all so what I found in Vegas
is every from one point to another it's
within 30 minutes no matter where you
and there was no traffic and everybody
you're you can now become a destination
spot for when people come in from from
where wherever they're at yeah where we
at have you already experienced that
where like people are like yo I came
into town I got to come through I we
just posted it somebody said they came
to Vegas there's there's a first stop
cuz they know this that we were there
and be before when they were in La they
can't make it so now they go there well
more people go to Vegas than La I feel
like you know La is they go to
Disneyland you know you how many
Disneyland trips you take per year
exactly so
Vegas lot of people take it for leisure
and work there's a lot of convention
going
a lot of Stu going on Vegas is uh so
business has been booming it's been
great uh it's been doing well um so you
know there might be a I don't know if I
should say it but should I say it what
designer con will be in Vegas next year
too wow yeah so this is our last year
anah hype so if you've never been and
you're in La you should go to
designer.com grab your tickets get the
VIP that's still available for Friday
night grab the Jordan if you can I'm
sure to sell out um there a lot of ton
of exclusives uh special guest and then
Saturday we have signings just a bunch
of cool stuff probably will'll see you
there I'll be there people get to see
you um I'll be there but yeah this will
be our last year you know when we turn
18 we got to go to leave our Nest Hey
listen I am excited because now I have
an excuse to go to Vegas any excuse to
go to Vegas is a good excuse in Vegas I
already have things planned oh it's
going to be crazy I'm sure yo um um last
question I I'm wondering we talked
earlier about your personal collection
what is a toy you'll never sell that you
own that just means something to you
that you just like that you love that
just I mean I won't say never sure
somebody gave you $10 million yourself
but in terms of like terms yeah I get
you I get you uh I think my car there's
three th% bear Breck cars I have those
three that's I got it for retail like
500 bucks now they're 25,000 each right
so yes I can sell it
but then that's something that I don't
know if I I could personally pay 25
Grand on a toy I don't know if I can do
that yeah right so I that's probably I
won't sell and then another figure I
have was the one that got me into all
this was a Stuy figure that's like a
skateboarder that Stuy used to sell them
20 years ago the store that was the
first figure that I ever bought so
that's what kind of got you in yeah I'm
like this thing is cool cuz I'm a big
guy yeah I couldn't fit there their
clothes right buy something so buy the
accessories buy the Hat buy the yeah
yeah so like that's how I got into it
like oh I can buy something and it's a
cool little figure and that kind of got
me into the rabbit hole of designer toys
from kit robot to metacom that kit robot
had a wave man I remember they had that
store in Vegas too 10 10 years 15 years
15 glorious years of and then they kind
of just you know it's unfortunate you
know we are we are celebrating uh the
life of Frank Kik this year at the show
he unfortunately passed away this year
he was the creative director kobot of
the last few years um yeah so like we'll
be remembering him there great panels
too I think amen's doing something in
theop hip-hop like I told him you know I
would love him to him and Destroy is
carting a a whole day so Sunday will be
uh hip-hop and art like what does that
mean with each other right a lot of
artists that that comes through our show
like uh Ms like he was part of a a booth
last year yeah and he's got I mean he's
had his own comic I have a signed copy
of his comic book from like 10 years ago
so people in Hip Hop have done stuff in
the Collectibles world for sure all the
time I mean [__] run the jewels got some
sick toys The Ghost Face Killer [__]
exactly so like there was a Rizza toy I
want to say last year that was in the
middle there was like you guys had that
middle I forget what company it was but
they had the middle big booth and they
had all this stuff it was like Network
yes and they had I think it was a Rizza
toy yeah I think so it was like a Rizza
Kill Bill toy maybe they they they have
some I was like [__] should have got
here Friday right look um so he's going
to have a whole Sunday planning about it
you know we're celebrating the 50 hiop
hipop so I I hit up Amy man I'm like hey
you should we should do something you
know uh so he's doing that Sunday with a
bunch of cool cool cool people artists
musicians together on Sunday sick well
listen go uh make sure you get your
tickets make sure you uh support 3D
retro too if you're in Vegas Yes uh
what's ig's ig's i i 3D retro is for the
Instagram and designercon is designercon
go get your tickets last year in La man
last year appreciate you pulling up man
thank you for having me yes sir boom can
we show some love to our family at
harden man shout out to harden man look
if you're in Vegas you got to pull up
you got to say take me to harden right
now I need to go to harden they're going
to take you they're going to get you
situated Harden Las Vegas the best
cannabis uh dispensary I've ever walked
into in my life the most craziest
selection of Premium cannabis in the
entire world I mean that place smells
like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Hardin Las Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
Las vegas.com and when you're in Vegas
make sure you pull up to hardine baby